[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zur Sallys Welt!
Ich habe mir gedacht,
Geschenke aus der Küche wären doch mal
was richtig Cooles,
was ihr auch jetzt an Weihnachten verschenken könnt,
gerade jetzt, wo man eben viele Freunde
und Verwandte und Familie einfach nicht sehen kann.
Aber so eine kleine Geste ist doch echt auch was Schönes.
Und Geschenke aus der Küche
müssen ja nicht unbedingt bedeuten,
dass man sie essen kann.
Deswegen, habe ich mir gedacht, machen wir heute
so ein bisschen was für die Körperpflege zum Entspannen.
Zum einen gibt es jetzt Badekugeln
und dann machen wir noch eine Seife
und vielleicht machen wir sogar noch ein Peeling.
Das sehen wir dann.
Also für die Badebomben
– ich mache ja diese Badekugeln –
verwende ich später einfach Eiswürfelformen.
Ihr könnt aber auch
– das gibt es oft in diesen Badekugelsets,
dass man so zwei Halbkugeln hat wie diese Anhänger.
Die gibt es im Bastelladen.
Aber ich habe mir jetzt gedacht:
Komm, für was nicht einfach diese Eiswürfelform benutzen.
Die kriegt man da ja auch super wieder raus,
weil sie eben so einen Silikonboden haben.
Und dann kann man eben auch was nutzen,
was man eh schon zu Hause hat.
Ich verwende dafür
200 Gramm Natron,
100 Gramm Zitronensäure,
70 Gramm Speisestärke,
100 Gramm Kokosöl.
Und hier habe ich noch ätherische Öle
und etwas Lebensmittelfarbe.
Natron und Zitronensäure gibt es auch im Supermarkt,
in jedem.
Also da könnt ihr gerne mal schauen.
Natron gibt es in der Backabteilung,
Zitronensäure gibt es in der Putzabteilung.
Es steht sogar meist noch dabei
"lebensmittelechte Zitronensäure".
Aber, wie gesagt, es wird ja jetzt hier nicht gegessen,
sondern eben zum Baden verwendet.
Die zwei werden jetzt mal vermischt.
Die habe ich eigentlich immer im Haushalt,
weil ich damit auch gerne putze
und Reiniger selber herstelle.
Dann die Stärke, die bindet das Ganze,
dass es eben auch eine schöne, feste Form bleibt.
Kokosöl ist je nach Raumtemperatur flüssig oder fest.
Also im Sommer habe ich es immer
recht flüssig in meinem Küchenschrank.
Aber das ist im Prinzip egal,
weil es später sowieso in den Kühlschrank kommt.
Okay.
Das ist jetzt die Grundsubstanz.
Das Kokosöl
kommt hier jetzt auch rein.
Und da ist es einfach so,
dass Kokosöl natürlich auch die Haut pflegt
und so einen gewissen Duftstoff
natürlich auch schon mit reinbringt.
Und es wird eben im kalten Zustand schön fest.
Jetzt die Zutaten hier vermischen.
[Musik]
Und ich habe jetzt hier übrigens Handschuhe an,
einfach, um die Hände zu schützen.
Denn ich werde ja auch gleich noch Farbe benutzen.
Und hier könnt ihr jetzt Öl mit reingeben.
Ich nehme jetzt das Eukalyptusöl.
Ein paar Tröpfchen.
Das riecht gut.
Ich glaube, ich werde jetzt sogar
diese Masse noch zweimal herstellen.
Denn dann habe ich genügend Badebomben.
Die lasse ich jetzt weiß.
Und die anderen zwei färbe ich dann grün und rot.
Ich glaube, so fühlen sich doch so diese bösen Gangster,
die in der Garage böse Dinge anmischen.
[Musik]
Darf ich die Brille wieder ausziehen?
Die sieht schon bescheuert aus.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich fühle mich so richtig bescheuert.
Und bei der Farbe einfach eine Lebensmittelfarbe nehmen.
Die geht nämlich ganz einfach von der Haut weg,
färbt halt die Haut auch gar nicht in der Badewanne.
Aber ich meine, das Wasser wird ja dann wirklich
nicht wirklich grün,
nur weil ich jetzt ein bisschen Grün drin habe.
Aber auch gerade mit Acrylbadewannen aufpassen
und deswegen Lebensmittelfarben benutzen.
Die sind dann auch für den Körper nicht schädlich
und eben auch für die Badewanne nicht.
Jetzt habe ich hier die Eiswürfelförmchen.
Wenn ihr möchtet, könnt ihr noch kleine Streusel mit reingeben,
also Zuckerstreusel
oder auch kleine Sternchen,
alles, was schön weihnachtlich/winterlich aussieht.
Die gebe ich jetzt hier unten rein.
Denn das sieht man ja dann von unten.
[Musik]
Ich mache das in den Komplementärfarben.
Bei Rot und Grün mache ich bei Rot die grünen Streuselchen.
Aber bei Weiß lasse ich, glaube ich
– ach, ich weiß noch nicht.
Ich mache es, glaube ich, kunterbunt.
[Musik]
Und jetzt könnt ihr hier einfach die Masse reindrücken.
Und dann ist wichtig, dass sie wirklich reingepresst wird,
damit die Badekugeln später auch schön zusammenbleiben.
Ihr könnt auch einen Gegenstand nehmen,
so ein Holz zum Beispiel und so richtig fest reindrücken.
Ich hatte mal so einen Muffinformdrücker.
Aber der ist nicht mehr da.
Mittlerweile hat sich die Versuchswerkstatt vergrößert.
Nicht mischen, haben wir gesagt, bei den ersten jetzt.
>> SAMIRA: Ich freue mich auf das Mittagessen.
>> SALLY: Mit den restlichen dürft ihr mischen, okay?
Dann lasst mich jetzt mal kurz...
Nein, nein, nein.
Dann lasst mich jetzt mal kurz fertig machen.
Guck mal, Schatzi. Wenn du so machst
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> SALLY: und dann rein, dann hast du außen nicht so viel,
was später dann praktisch nicht...
Weil das außen, diese Krümelchen,
die fallen ja dann weg. Weißt du?
[Musik]
Yes!
So. Jetzt habe ich sie hier angedrückt.
Was jetzt wichtig ist:
Das Ganze kommt jetzt in den Kühlschrank,
muss fest werden für ungefähr fünf, sechs Stunden.
Dann nehme ich es raus,
stürze sie auch heraus
und werde sie dann aber etwa zwei Tage trocknen lassen.
Dann wird das Fett schön fest,
alle flüssigen Bestandteile trocknen.
Und dann kann man sie verpacken.
Also das ist jetzt einfach nur noch eine Wartezeit,
die man hat.
Und wir machen noch weitere.
Guck mal, Ela, da vorne drin sind Eisförmchen.
Holst du noch welche?
[Musik]
Kommen wir zur zweiten Idee, nämlich Seife selber machen.
Und ich habe dafür Seife bestellt.
Also selber machen heißt so viel wie Seife aufpimpen.
Ich habe hier Glyzerinseife bestellt,
einmal transparent,
einmal weiß, wie ihr sehen könnt.
Und dann nehme ich auch wieder die Eiswürfelförmchen,
wobei ich hier auch diese länglichen habe, also diese Stäbe.
Die nehme ich wahrscheinlich auch.
Ich habe hier Farbpaste in Lila,
Lavendelöl
und Lavendel aus meinem Garten.
Und da werde ich es jetzt so machen,
dass ich die Seife schmelze
in der Mikrowelle.
Im Wasserbad geht aber auch.
[Musik]
Ich glaube, ich nehme mal zwei weniger.
Nicht, dass es mir überläuft in der
Mikrowelle.
Also kurz in der Mikrowelle verflüssigen.
[Musik]
Jetzt haben wir hier Kamerakind Samira an der Zweitkamera.
Können wir sie mal zeigen?
Da in die Kamera.
Hi!
Super Job bisher! Super Job!
Sehr gut, sehr gut. Sitzt die Schärfe?
>> SAMIRA: Die Schärfe sitzt.
>> SALLY: Sehr gut!
Also die Seifen sind geschmolzen.
Jetzt gebe ich hier jeweils Lavendelöl rein.
Wie gesagt, auch hier könnt ihr wieder andere Düfte nehmen,
Orange, Zitrone, was auch immer ihr wollt.
Rosmarin ist auch cool in so einer Seife.
Und ich nehme Lila Farbpaste.
Das ist auch wieder Lebensmittelfarbe.
Ganz wenig.
Ich möchte so einen leichten Fliederton haben.
[Musik]
Okay, ich werde es kurz pürieren,
damit sich die Farbe besser löst.
[Musik]
Ich denke, es wäre auch besser gewesen,
einfach eine kleine Menge flüssige Seife
mit der Farbe zu vermischen und dann wieder zurück.
Es war mein Fehler.
Egal.
Ich hoffe, das setzt sich wieder.
Wenn nicht, schmelze ich es noch mal
und mache es dann so wie gerade eben vorgeschlagen.
Und jetzt werde ich einmal Stäbchen machen
und einmal so
und die jetzt hier befüllen.
Bei einigen werde ich am Boden
einfach noch Lavendel verteilen,
damit man das auch sieht.
[Musik]
Die muss ich jetzt im Prinzip
nur fest werden lassen.
[Musik]
Oh! Das riecht hier echt lecker.
Echt gut!
Ich liebe Lavendel.
[Musik]
Also die lasse ich jetzt hier auch fest werden.
Und dann gibt es noch ein Körperpeeling.
[Musik]
Die Badebomben habe ich jetzt
aus den Silikonformen rausgelöst.
Die Seife ist auch schon fertig.
Jetzt geht es im Prinzip noch an das dritte Rezept
und das wird ein Körperpeeling.
Und da habe ich jetzt bewusst ein Körperpeeling gemacht
und kein Gesichtspeeling.
Denn beim Gesicht ist ja jeder so ein bisschen eigen.
Also ich würde mir jetzt
auch kein Peeling ins Gesicht schmieren,
von dem ich nicht weiß, was da drin steckt.
Aber ein Körperpeeling gerade so für unter die Dusche
jetzt im Winter ist doch echt ganz cool.
Und das mache ich, wie gesagt, auch aus guten Zutaten.
Da weiß man, was drin steckt,
und es ist einfach eine schöne Geste.
Ich habe mich jetzt hier einfach für die Variante entschieden
Kokos, Honig und brauner Zucker mit Orange.
Aber auch hier könnt ihr natürlich den Duft verändern
oder auch die Inhaltsstoffe verändern,
je nachdem, wofür ihr eben brennt
und was euch so am liebsten ist.
Dafür nehme ich
160 Gramm Kokosöl,
160 Gramm Honig,
320 Gramm Zucker,
– ich habe jetzt hier den braunen Zucker –
eine Orange
und etwas Orangenöl.
Und das ist jetzt wirklich supereinfach.
Ihr gebt einfach die Zutaten hier rein.
Heute ist das Kokosöl sehr fest,
da die Küche heute sehr kalt ist.
Ich friere sogar ein bisschen, muss ich sagen.
Und statt Kokosöl könnt ihr hier
zum Beispiel auch ein Mandelöl nehmen
oder was komplett anderes, was ihr einfach wollt.
Honig.
[Musik]
Dieses Peeling würde man am Ende am liebsten essen.
Ich nehme jetzt hier den braunen Zucker.
Wenn ihr den normalen weißen Zucker nehmt,
wird das Peeling von der Farbe her einfach heller.
Und ich finde, so sieht es einfach so ein bisschen,
ja, einfach noch natürlicher aus.
Jetzt hier einfach verrühren.
Und das riecht jetzt momentan nach Honig und Kokos
und ich verfeinere es mit Orange.
Aber auch hier, wie gesagt,
einfach einen Duft nehmen, den ihr mögt.
Bei der Orange mache ich es so,
dass ich jetzt hier den Abrieb mit dazu gebe,
auch gerade so für die Optik.
Ich habe jetzt hier so einen Zestenreißer.
Mit dem reiße ich sozusagen
diese kleinen Kringelchen hier ab.
Es riecht natürlich auch gleich extrem gut,
weil die ätherischen Öle sich verbreiten.
Und die Orange, die presse ich einfach aus
und gebe sie zu meinem Wasser.
Hier habe ich noch ein Orangenöl.
Das nehme ich normalerweise zum Backen.
Es ist auch reines Orangenöl, 100 Prozent.
Es ist sogar wirklich für die Lebensmittel gedacht,
zum Verzehr.
Und das ist wirklich aus einer Orange einfach gemacht,
aus der Orangenschale.
Und da erhalte ich einfach noch mal den konzentrierteren Duft.
Was auch gut passen würde, wäre Vanille.
Also Vanilleschote, Vanilleextrakt
könnt ihr auch dazu geben.
Dann habt ihr so Orange, Vanille, Kokos.
Aber so gefällt es mir echt gut.
Und das ist jetzt hier diese Konsistenz.
Wie gesagt, wenn die Küche ein bisschen wärmer ist,
kann es ein bisschen flüssiger auch sein durch das Kokosöl.
Kokosöl ist ja auch
ein super Feuchtigkeitsspender für die Haut,
lindert sogar Hautreizungen
und kann eben auch antibakteriell wirken.
Und deswegen
– ich benutze es auch tatsächlich oft gerne zum Abschminken,
so Kokosöl und dann Rosenwasser drüber.
Und dann ist wirklich alles komplett sauber und weg.
Und jetzt könnt ihr entweder so kleine Weckgläschen nehmen
oder Einmachgläser mit Schraubdeckel
und die dann schön dekorieren
oder ihr nehmt andere Gläschen.
Ihr könnt aber auch hergehen und sagen:
Reagenzgläsern, die sind auch echt süß.
Also da könnt ihr jetzt im Prinzip entscheiden,
wie viel ihr praktisch vom Peeling verschenken wollt,
wie groß die Verpackung sein soll
und, ja, wie ihr es eben am Ende dekorieren wollt.
[Musik]
Jetzt kam mir noch spontan eine vierte Idee
und zwar ein Badesalz selber machen.
Dafür nehme ich hier einfach ein bisschen grobes Meersalz
und getrocknete Blüten.
Im Prinzip ist dieses Badesalz auch zum Verzehr geeignet,
also eigentlich alles, was wir jetzt hier gemacht haben,
außer die Seifen und natürlich die Badebomben.
Im Prinzip kann man es zum Verzehr nehmen.
Wenn ihr hier beispielsweise noch Pfeffer dann dazu gebt,
könnt ihr auch sagen, es ist ein Salatsalz.
Denn ich persönlich mag es ganz gerne,
wenn ich getrocknete Blüten in meinem Salat habe.
Ich mache die total häufig rein,
weil sie einfach einen supertollen Geschmack geben.
Das sind hier so Kornblumen, Hagebutte,
also eine ganz, ganz tolle Mischung.
Aber jetzt sind wir ja bei DIY Non-Food-Geschenke.
Deswegen machen wir es als Badesalz.
Und im Prinzip mischt ihr einfach beide Zutaten zusammen,
je nachdem, wie viel ihr eben auch machen möchtet.
[Musik]
Und wenn ihr möchtet,
könnt ihr auch hier wieder ätherische Öle dazu geben.
Also, wenn es ein Badesalz werden soll,
Eukalyptus, Pfefferminze,
alles, was ihr eben gerne im Badesalz mit drin habt.
Und wenn es ein Salatsalz werden soll,
dann am besten kein Eukalyptus,
Orange oder was weiß ich, was für Öle.
Ich nehme jetzt hier einen Trichter
und fülle die Reagenzgläser damit.
[Musik]
Ich finde, so was ist nicht nur
ein hübsches Weihnachtsgeschenk,
das geht einfach immer.
Und wenn man sich so was auf Vorrat macht,
– ich meine, das wird ja nicht schlecht,
Salz wird nicht schlecht, Zucker wird nicht schlecht –
dann hat man einfach immer was,
was man auch mal mitnehmen kann,
wenn man irgendwo mal eingeladen ist, so zu Gast.
Einfach immer so ein schönes selbst gemachtes Mitbringsel.
Es gibt Mitbringsel.
Das ist das, was man mitnimmt, wenn man wohin geht.
Und neulich habe ich,
als ich Elas und Samiras Kindergeburtstag so geplant habe
– okay, Samiras nicht, der fiel ja aus Lockdown-bedingt.
Aber Elas fand noch statt im kleinen Rahmen.
Und dann habe ich so geguckt nach Mitgebsel.
Weil auf Kindergeburtstagen ist es ja so,
dass man da den Kindern was mitgibt.
Und das sind die Mitgebsel.
Und ich dachte immer,
das wäre so ein Dialektwort bei uns hier,
so ein Mitgebsel.
Aber es stand sogar online auf so einer Kinder-Homepage,
so ein Produkt was man bestellen konnte, so diese Tüten
und da stand wirklich "Mitgebseltüte".
Und ich dachte so: Mitgebsel, Mitbringsel.
>> JOSH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Sagt ihr mal, ob ihr das so auch kennt.
Ja.
[Musik]
Guckt einmal, wie schön das aussieht!
Und ich nehme alles zurück,
was ich gerade eben gesagt habe.
Ich habe ja gesagt, ihr könnt noch ätherische Öle zufügen,
Eukalyptus, Pfefferminze.
Tut es nicht, denn diese Blüten, die riechen so gut.
Man hat so ein richtiges, schönes Blumenbad dann.
Also das riecht echt gut.
Da würde ich echt nichts mehr dazu machen.
Und vor allem, wenn ihr nichts mehr dazu gebt,
könnt ihr sagen:
Ich nehme es für Salat oder ich nehme es für zum Baden.
Das könnt ihr dann entscheiden.
[Musik]
Wir dekorieren jetzt hier gerade alle Geschenke.
Und gerade beim Dekorieren fällt mir dann eben auch ein,
wie man es schön hübsch verpacken kann
und dann eben verschenken kann.
Also, was ich auf jeden Fall machen würde, wäre,
so ein kleines Schild dran zu hängen,
dass eben auch dran steht, was drin ist,
damit auch die Menschen, die beschenkt werden,
wissen, was sie eben auf ihre Haut streichen.
Samira, du kannst vielleicht
für dieses Peeling
einen schönen Löffel holen
oder Sarah mal fragen, welche Löffelfarbe sie braucht.
[Musik]
Guckt mal. Hier sind jetzt die vier Artikel
– Artikel sage ich schon,
die vier Produkte, die ich selbst gemacht habe.
Zum einen die Badebomben,
die man wirklich ganz einfach
in etwas Badewasser auflösen kann.
Haben wir ja auch schon zusammen gemacht
für so ein kleines Sprudelbad.
Das Badesalz,
was man eben auch einfach in warmes Wasser mischt.
Hier die Handseife,
die man eben zum Händewaschen benutzt.
Und das Körperpeeling.
Und gerade das Körperpeeling, muss ich sagen,
es macht halt wirklich eine supergeschmeidige Haut,
spendet Feuchtigkeit und pflegt die Haut.
Und auch bei den anderen Produkten muss man sagen,
dass sie die Haut sehr gut pflegen,
vor allem auch die Badebomben
auch mit dem Kokosfett mit dabei.
Das Salz ist natürlich einfach
eher so ein kosmetisches Produkt.
Meersalz im Badewasser ist natürlich wunderbar
und durch die Blüten hat man eben diesen tollen Duft.
Und Lavendelöl, muss ich persönlich sagen,
ist auch einer meiner Favoriten.
Denn ich mag Lavendelöl
zum einen auch ganz gerne im Gesicht,
also auch mal zum Abschminken und Reinigen
oder eben auch einfach zur Pflege.
Und ich mag es auch ganz gerne,
weil es eben beruhigend wirkt.
Also es hat echt so eine schöne, beruhigende Wirkung.
Und wenn ihr das Ganze eben hübsch verpackt,
– ich habe jetzt hier die Seifen so einzeln verpackt
und hier könnte wirklich schön
mit Geschenkbändchen und Anhängern arbeiten –
dann ist es doch eine richtig tolle Geschenkidee
aus eurer eigenen Küche.
Und das könnt ihr auch super mit Kindern zusammen machen.
Aber du bist ja schon so ein großes Kind,
du kannst sowieso alles alleine machen.
>> SAMIRA: Eigentlich könnte man
hier so ein Loche reinmachen und dann so als Armband.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Dann hat man so eine Seife immer dabei,
so zum Händewaschen.
Also schreibt mir gerne, wie ihr diese Ideen fandet
und ob ich gerne weitere Ideen machen soll,
die auch mal nicht essbar sind.
Schreibt es gerne in die Kommentare, wenn wir mal weiter
in so Richtung Naturkosmetik auch gehen wollen.
Und ich freue mich auf eure Rückmeldungen,
freue mich auf eure Fotos, die ihr machen werdet.
Und
jetzt gehen wir und baden, oder?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Das würde ich jetzt auch sagen.
Schnappen wir uns die Badebomben
oder ich das Badesalz
und das Peeling.
Tschüss!
>> SAMIRA: Ich auch.
[Musik]